welcome to this video playing fishbowl
there's a master fishbowl no name a
pretty new account are not very well
used account let's see I'm going afore
for change and have the Russell limo
variation okie dokie net stick and go
from here I really don't know that too
well this recently was played in this
some Carlton a koala cards and game in
the bike I'm going to play for for f4
Here I am a form I could have played
Bishop h6e actually may be here you take
this chance okay Teague's and everyone I
think this is how it is played widest
try to play on the dark squares isn't
this kind of good for me this looks very
shaky from black now ok he will get too
careful but I wonder it's there some way
here maybe to play it aggressively you
not to let him try to try to not to let
him get away with this so easily be five
maybe it's maybe interesting 90x90 for
looks a nice and Ponte accessor is at
least an interesting position to age
friars again attending 90 form g5 I have
the check possibly or queen g3 if he
goes rook f8 I play Knight f3 I guess
Queen e7 I have queen age 6
it's interesting a compensation I guess
so the check is Queen g6 I can take then
at night f3 which is not a bad position
but trading Queens us really meek you
have it's a really neat decision I
really don't want that he has a hard
time to get his King out of the middle
so G for night takes d5 her this is
almost winning I guess if he goes gee
for looks really like a bad decision
oops I can take right and Queen takes
rook e1 or Knight takes rook e1 that
looks really bad now we're looking
something that really looks like a
straightforward very good position so
root K exam is 94 even better no jack
let's take care where the rook must be
good really okay so nighty for I guess
you're pushing getting this piece into
the game would be quite amazing if this
wasn't good am they were threatening
work t5 or something it's not not yet
decisive but it looks really bad Knight
f6 is the the simple way to play Knight
f6 but how do I win then
if i go to g5 has got this check which
is not not really nice to face but it's
not really a problem right this check it
really is just the check yeah we can
give this check i go to h1 look f7 and
26 and really big threats both both at
the same time looks like a bit much
maybe I had like I don't know I don't
know this looks simple and good look at
7a some
it's the idea now so check
so i can take and play Jack Quincy sound
check commun d7 rook f7 check check
check black resign yeah that was a bit
of an opening disaster I feel like if we
if we go here this is this is certainly
kind of normal but I don't know that
Bishop age six I think they normally
prevent this kind of thing I don't know
I could have played it right away so
something like that is definitely
definitely a line I mean but this
something is not quite right him maybe
he has to do something like that so that
the night is looking at this square so
f4 is not easily possible yeah that's
definitely okay from like the we pleaded
this already looks I don't know I mean
the thing is if he allows structure
let's say it plays a move like that and
he allows this structure this will be
like I mean this is just the torture for
black because II five is a report which
can be pressurized Knight f3 Queen to g3
whatever and he cannot ever protect it
obviously with the bishop on e6 oh this
is just a very inconvenient position and
if you want to avoid that what are you
playing I mean he went went with this
but how are you how are you avoiding the
situation this blocks your development I
just go here and win you the idea maybe
here you can take and castle maybe
this is still this is a bad version of
this opening for lucky somehow has lost
right now there is something wrong here
simply and yeah this is a very nice
position yeah if I have debatable
debatable if this is necessary or if it
is good or whatever way it's a very it's
a powerful move maybe that's that's
let's see I mean after the pawn takes I
feel it should be a really nice and here
maybe here there is something I wanted
to play nighty form but here the
computer is just very very it just says
f5 and black is fine okay now this is
the kind of move where you check as a
human are somewhat skeptical this is the
computer line now it gives before it's a
very cute move very doubtful if I would
have played that one well very very nice
track here this this is protected now
cannot cannot play the night if he takes
d4 mmm very messy stuff it's clearly
better than what he did i'm in here it
really will be very difficult to play
Queen e7 us know maybe better and here
yeah here already he was already about a
technical solution edges this is
definitely good for why there without
any doubt look at this the structure I
will get something back and have a goods
I mean the remaining structure is
fantastic and I'm not materially down i
would get something back some but i
wanted to keep queens on at this
definitely
some paid off yeah GM's just a question
of how quick do you want to win if I was
even the best movie I wasn't sure if I
was already made the computer finds a
mate funny yeah this is kind of
graphical user interface you just + + +
99 which means there is some kind of
made but I don't know how many moves
check yeah yeah check check check this
wins the house yeah that was suppose
canned of nice and show us that even
with this somewhat slow Sicilians you
can sometimes get nice attacking
positions you hope you like that thanks
for watching